hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
preview about the Game of Thrones season
seven finale but first I wanted to tell
you about an app I've been using Thrones
Amino is the ultimate social community
dedicated to obsessed G ot fans it has
loads of features to provide a game of
Thrones fix anytime including a front
page with featured posts public chats
quizzes and lots of polls to participate
in what's nice is that you can create
any of these yourself I like taking the
quizzes personally but there is a nice
variety of posts to browse through since
the community is super active a
partnered with Thrones Amino to bring
this to you but I'm also an active
member so check the video description to
download the app and follow me on throne
Cimino fans can read up on interesting
theories doing in on public chat rooms
voting polls take quizzes and nerd out
on all things geot related
all right so I mentioned in my trailer
breakdown for Episode seven now what's
interesting about this episode is
probably what we didn't see in the
trailer we got a lot of photos from HBO
already and we learned this to title is
the dragon and the wolf which is awesome
but they didn't give up much in any of
the photos the name is so exciting
because this episode is long and what's
little to go off we have to accept
expect some big surprises for those of
you that have been watching my videos
for a while you know I watched the set
filming and preseason stuff really
closely and even with all of that
there's still a lot of unknown stuff for
this episode
most of the location stuff has already
been aired and even though we knew that
this big meeting was going to happen in
the dragon pit details about what's
gonna actually go on there are
completely sparse the big thing that is
driving the hype for the dragon and the
wolf is exactly that the name of the
episode you might think that refers to
Daenerys and John or if you're weird
just John himself but that would only be
part of what this is about as far as I'm
concerned the real meaning of the title
is almost surely a reference to Rhaegar
and Lyanna Jon Snow's parents and I
think it's safe to say we're gonna get a
flashback after all John is part wolf
and part dragon because of his parents
and even though there's probably going
to be some movement in his relationship
with Daenerys this is what it's really
hinting at what will the flashback be
though gillies already tipped us off
that an annulment and marriage has
happened so it could be that but I think
it's a little underwhelming to show
their wedding after we already know that
they add one what else is there then
well my guess is that part of the
tourney at Harrenhal is actually
possible and there's even some
circumstantial evidence to back this up
I made a video about the tourney at
Harrenhal
history and lore clip that they put out
last year and the fact that they added
it could be a hit in itself like so they
wanted to get
on book-reading fans to have more of an
idea of what the tourney was but the big
kind of thing in the clip was that they
left the Rhaegar out of it completely
they talked about Howland and his
experience and they talked about Liana
and her part in it but there was no
mention of Rhaegar at all at the time it
felt like it was a setup to a flashback
that involved him especially because
there were rumors going around at that
time that the different actors may have
been cast to play him in season seven
since then folks on reddit may have
figured out who the actor is based on
the HBO hack and the fact that the actor
in question had followed the actress who
played Leon the stark in last year's
tower joy flashback again circumstantial
evidence but if you combine that with
the title of the season 7 finale it
pretty much adds up I'll be really
surprised if there isn't a flashback and
with such a long episode it's possible
that it could be a whole segment rather
than just a quick glimpse like there
could be multiple parts of their history
that we see but who knows I mean we have
no idea most likely this will come
through bran at the heart tree in
Winterfell but that's just an educated
guess
the next big event that comes to mind is
whether or not the night king will
breach the wall and head into Westeros
with his army before there were leaks or
anything else this was always expected
to be the big end of the season event in
season 7 that way it would set up the
war for the dawn in season 8 in the
books most people assume that the wall
will fall in the last chapter of winds
of winter and whether that's from Iran
getting a hold of the Horn of winter and
blowing it or some other event that
overpowers the magic that's built in the
wall the common consensus is that it
will fall in the show the night King has
got himself a dragon and I don't know
how it will be explained magically but
this probably will play a part in some
way after the night king touch bran last
season it became a popular theory that
he would be able to pass because of that
but some time has passed in between and
I was never sure how I thought about
that
anyways one thing seems certain the wall
that has separated the White Walkers
from mankind for the last 8,000 or so
years won't likely be standing at the
beginning of season 8 a lot of people
had commented in the trailer breakdown
that they thought that or they were
expecting I should say Cersei that would
be setting a trap in King's Landing
during the meeting at the dragon pit I
don't think that's gonna happen for a
couple of reasons one is that as I
mentioned I think the focus is going to
the White Walkers filling into Westeros
so unless this would lead to Cersei
dying and everyone else getting away it
seems unlikely another reason is because
the crown should have some interest in
what's going on or happening in the
north because people have heard the
stories about the long night I'm not
saying she'll help fight the night King
and even if she does agree to help I
would expect that it's not exactly
something you could trust but in order
for John and Daenerys to team up and
focus on the north Cersei has to at
least agree to put a hold on the war for
Westeros the photos HBO release seemed
to foreshadow tension between Jaime and
Cersei beyond that they don't give us
much to think about we see similar shots
of King's Landing like we saw in the
trailer but the one of them arguing
seems to be the biggest one that stands
out there are some new images of Theon
which I hope means we get some movement
in his story since he didn't go north
with Jon we haven't heard anything about
what's going on with him or any Greyjoy
for quite a while there is the shot of
him breaking down more or less on the
beach which a lot of people commented
might be related to Yara and her dying
and then him finding out but honestly I
have no idea since the last time we saw
her was in King's Landing being led away
by uncle you're on your own hasn't been
on camera since either but he has been
seen using his fleet to go up against
the unsullied outside Casterly Rock
I was expecting some scenes of him
torturing her on his ship or something
to give us an idea of where they were
but it's a complete mystery at this
point from the trailer we know Theon is
headed to King's Landing with Tyrion but
all we get from the new photos is that
he looks to have some scenes on the
beach of Dragonstone
as well there are no photos of
Littlefinger but we did get some of
Sansa and bran I know a lot of people
think that Littlefinger is gonna die in
this episode but the story and
Winterfell is pretty well it's pretty
well hard to get at this point from what
we've seen it seems like there would be
I mean there'd have to be some kind of
big movement with the Starks to get to a
point where they're killing finger I
mean they're not really there yet that
said the photos of Brandon could be
pointing us in that direction but at the
same time that could just be related to
him telling someone about what he's seen
with John's parentage based on the other
stuff that we know it's been in the
worst part of the last couple episodes I
think is there Winterfell scenes I guess
at the end of the day I just hope that
it makes sense like I could care less
whether Littlefinger dies or not it's
really not that important to me right
now the way that things were set up he's
kind of neutralized up there in anyways
I mean sure he's dangerous to have
around but you think they'd be building
it up if we're supposed to be really
pumped to get him out of the picture you
know what I mean there are no sightings
of Sam or Gilly in any of the material
that we saw I'm guessing we'll see them
arrive at Winterfell by the end of the
episode of that's where they're headed
but there's really nothing to go off on
that front we really have no idea if the
maesters ever told him about his father
and his brother or if anyone else has
passed that on on the road because we
haven't seen him so there's nothing that
would have sent him to home before that
but if he found that out I guess he
might go there I pretty much thought
that he'd be going to Winterfell or to
the wall but we'll just have to wait and
see also still no shots of Daenerys at
the dragon pit I mentioned in the
trailer breakdown that my guest there is
that she'll make an entrance on drogon
after the others are in place there's
another shots of Brienne and pod either
in the King's Landing stuff but we do
know they made it to there from
Winterfell
from the trailer we could see them
walking behind Jon most everyone else
was accounted for in those photos of
what as well I mentioned that the hound
wasn't in the forefront but it's a
pretty likely situation that he'll be
leading in the white based on the fact
that we saw him in the first trailer in
the dragon pit so he's definitely gonna
be there there's a lot to I mean like I
said there's a lot of time that has to
be filled here so a lot of interesting
stuff that we don't know about could
happen what I'm hoping for like my wish
list of things that are just random I
guess is somewhat like something that
comes along to discredit this stupid
theory that bran is the knight Cain I
really don't like the theory and I
really don't want to spend the offseason
listening to people push it Brandon is
not the knight king in my opinion and I
hope there is some evidence of that in
the finale because it'll just keep being
recycled all offseason long also hoping
for anything that will discredit people
who think there've read the season 8
leaks watch was on the wall which is one
of my trusted most trusted sources of G
ot information has said what people are
pushing as leaks they're just made-up
stuff to capitalize on the news about
the hacks furthermore if there were
leaks they'd be posted and probably
pinned to the top of the free fall
credit and they aren't this is evidence
enough for me that there are no real
season 8 leaks out there but at the same
time people have been commenting now for
over a week that they think that they
know what happens because they read the
leaks and that will just continue all
the way until next season starts until
one of two things happen
one the actual story for season 8 gets
leaked or two that we find out something
that makes them definitely know that
that's false as far as other stuff is
concerned with regard Liana I would like
to see something even though we don't
ever know that they were at the Isle of
faces that's always been kind of a thing
that I wanted them to go there since she
follows the old gods and there at her
you know going past Harrenhal on the way
to Dorne so that would be cool if they
stopped off there because the tree you
know I don't know that would be cool
I've always wanted to see the Isle of
faces on the show and that
be something that I'd really like to see
I have real fear I mean I don't know if
the words fear but I have anxiety about
how they're gonna tackle the whole idea
of the White Walkers getting past the
wall I mean the walls been there for a
long time and we never really knew how
it worked or what was going on with it
coming down so I just hope it's a
satisfying story I mean everybody's
always expected it to come down but a
big part of that mythology has always
been that there's magic in there and
there needs to be some way that they get
past the magic so you know I'm kind of
hoping that it's not that he jumps on
Viserion and like goes there and starts
tearing it up or something stupid like
that or he freezes the water outside and
they walk around like those would be
hard things for me to come to terms with
I guess as far as the meeting at King's
Landing I think it'll be tense I think
there'll be some side meetings probably
with people it'll be interesting to see
if Varys meets up with little birds or
something like that there's not really
much bearish stuff in there or you know
something along those lines the general
idea at the beginning when we found out
all these people are gonna be in the
same place was that probably mr. C will
go along with it and then turn around
and double-cross them I think that kind
of makes the most sense like I said she
has to agree on some level in order for
the war to be put on hold or else she's
not given Daenerys a good reason not to
just burn King's Landing to the ground
and I don't think Cersei is necessarily
suicidal so you know people will say oh
well she doesn't want you know she has
wildfire and she'll burn it down you
know she might burn it down but she's
gonna kill herself in the process so I
would think that she wants to make peace
while they're there so that they can
stop all that and then John and Daenerys
will be able to team up and start
strategizing against the knight King in
his army which should be pouring into
Westeros by the end of the episode the
thing on stuff is a little bit you know
I was out there I don't know I had a
feeling that Yara would probably die
this season but we haven't had any
evidence of what's going on with her at
all I think like I said in my Theon in
John video I think he'll have a
redemption of some sort where he ends
doing something for John but again we
just don't have any clues as to what
he's been up to since he got back to
Dragonstone
I think brands big part here will be you
the same hopefully he'll just I mean he
could find out something about
Littlefinger and turn his sisters
against them or against him and sort out
that whole thing where they've been
fighting with each other or whatever but
I think he'll be essential now that we
know that the name of the episode is the
dragon and the wolf and bringing to
light whatever flashback there is that
we see alright guys hope you liked the
video make sure you tell me what you
think's gonna happen in this episode I
got a couple more that I'll be putting
out before the season finale airs please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already make sure you set notifications
so you will know when my new video comes
out don't forget to look in the comp the
description for the link to the Amino
app you can follow me over there I'll
put my username there as well and follow
me on Twitter and my other social media
accounts thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon